one of the key contributions that's
being made by Martin Luther King
Junior's letter from a Birmingham jail
has to do with the conception of law and
its relationship to morality and what
we're gonna see here he's going to talk
about just an unjust law and he's going
to put it in a context that has some
very traditional roots long-standing
roots in the the Western philosophical
and also religious tradition and we'll
talk about that in a moment but he's
also going to make some novel
contributions and talk in some very
helpful ways about how this would
actually apply in the situation of
American segregation and racism during
the civil rights struggle but also in
ways that would have a lot of
application today so what we're looking
at is nonviolent resistance to unjust
laws because that's exactly what landed
King and a number of other people in
jail in Birmingham so he's being accused
not only by the city of Birmingham but
also by his fellow pastors playing fast
and loose with the notion of legality
and he addresses an issue he says you
express a great deal of anxiety over our
willingness to break laws so what he
wants to do is provide some sort of very
clear criterion for saying which laws we
ought to obey and which laws we bought
not to obey or actually ought to break
he says since we so diligently urge
people to obey the Supreme Court's
decision outlawing segregation the
public schools it may at first glance
seem rather paradoxical for us
consciously to break laws so somebody
might ask how can you advocate breaking
some laws and obeying others what
they're looking for there is some sort
of consistency some sort of criterion
for what would allow a person to
actually break the laws King then says
there's two kinds of law
just laws those who actually should
follow we have no problem with those and
then there's unjust laws and he even
brings up st. Augustine to say an unjust
law in a certain sense isn't really a
law what king is doing is placing
himself within a historical tradition of
looking at laws one that comes to us in
large part through Christian thinkers
like Augustine he brings up Thomas
Aquinas a little bit later he's going to
talk about a contemporary Jewish thinker
and a contemporary Christian thinker
Martin Buber and Paul Tillich you know
he's going to try to answer the question
well what then actually makes laws just
so one way of talking about it and King
does this first he says a just lost
squares with the moral law or the law of
God so what does it mean to square with
he doesn't give you an awful lot there
because he's going to move on to that
very quickly but he says an unjust law
as a code that's out of harmony with the
moral law and here what we see is that I
make make some people very nervous that
he's talking about the law of God but
again within this this long-standing
Christian tradition of understanding
what the meaning of law is the law of
God and the moral law at least to some
degree overlap as a matter of fact one
of the important transitions that Thomas
Aquinas will talk about in moving from
the you know Jewish conception of law to
a later Christian conception of law
embodied in the New Testament is going
to be that the ceremonial stuff is going
to get left aside is not really being
important but that the moral law is
going to get actually reinforced so for
example the law against killing if you
look at the Sermon on the Mount which is
you know pretty typical articulation of
Christian ideas and values what what
Jesus tells the the gathered crowds is
the law says don't
kill but I tell you that if you get
angry with your your brother your fellow
human being your you know in a sense
killing him and so you know don't get
angry don't caught don't say Rocco's at
him you know raka sort of like you know
expressing anger and don't call him a
fool because if you do you're subject to
judgment instead you're supposed to
reconcile with with those and that's a
sort of further expression of what it
means not to kill likewise the
injunction against adultery you know on
the Sermon on the Mount it's you know
don't look at somebody else in lust
because you're committing adultery and
you're hurt
so the moral law and the law I've got to
square with them means to actually align
or harmonize with them laws that don't
harmonize with the moral law which is
being set up as a higher criterion for
man-made laws or human laws civil laws
as we call them laws that don't
harmonize that that aren't really laws
they're not really binding they don't
have the force behind them may be
difficult sometimes to distinguish
exactly what is in line with the moral
law and what's not depending on you know
how oh messed up ones moral compasses
order you know the society that you're
at another way that he talks about it
here he brings up Thomas Aquinas very
explicitly is that the just law is
rooted in the eternal law and natural
law now this is really you may sound
different to you but he's really saying
the same thing by this as he was by this
the eternal law according to Thomas
Aquinas is the law of God it's God as
law you know sort of putting something
out there into the entire universe
so the eternal law is you might say if
we have this is oversimplifying is God's
way of wanting things to be for the
entire cosmos down to the particulars
and human laws can participate in the
eternal law because we're that kind of
creature we have rationality we're able
to
you know have some part in Providence
this is what was Thomas Aquinas saying
that the real expression for human
beings takes place in terms of natural
law natural law for Thomas Aquinas is
not yet at the level of you know the
laws of the land the laws that law
givers are making it's more a set of
moral codes that we are able to grasp by
the use our human Faculty of Reason
applied to as Thomas says our
inclinations so if we look at our
inclination to continue in our own being
and sort of generalize that we realize
that life is something valuable and we
should not take life unless you know say
to prevent some some greater evil that
taking life in and of itself is a bad
thing so you know thou shalt not kill
can be understood as a commandment
coming from you know a religious text
but it can also be understood even with
you know if you don't have those
religious texts you can sort of look at
the fabric of the universe and our
inclinations and say yeah we shouldn't
kill people you can also derive not
stealing from that not violating you
know some sort of sexual norm in terms
of adultery not bearing false witness
that is not lie not not you know
corrupting the communicative situation
that we're in right so the natural law
is something that Thomas Aquinas thinks
that all rational reasonable
sufficiently developed human beings
ought to be able to grasp in its
generality not coming down yet to the
level of particulars it's one against
two particulars that it gets kind of
messy
so that provides us with another
criterion you know an unjust law is a
human law that's not rooted in eternal
law and natural law so to not be rooted
in those meanings that it doesn't have
any sort of basis it's not actually
doing what reason tells us we want to do
it might express some sort of feeling
like we ought to do this sort of thing
but it could be out of harmony with
these
so far king has just sort of echoed the
tradition at this point here he
introduces something new of his own a
new formulation a new way of thinking
out what all of this stuff here would
mean for the 20th and for the centuries
beyond the 20th century a just law he
says uplifts human personality an unjust
law by contrast what does it do
degrades human personality so we have a
new idea here human personality human
personhood what it means to be a human
being what it means to be a person so
there's a couple corollaries that we can
draw from this that help us think out
what this means a bit more concretely it
treats persons as persons not things
here he brings up Martin Buber Martin
Buber was this this Jewish philosopher
and theologian of the 20th century who
had this this wonderful book called eye
on down and in I and thou the central
idea is there are you know a
relationship between persons is an eye
thou or if you want to put it more
modern English eye you relationship or
you I know the ions over there who is me
right when we treat people as less than
people we treat them as an eye it
relationship so you know here's a great
example of this imagine that what I'm
talking to this camera the camera isn't
it it's an object it's just a thing but
it's a it's a thing through which I
actually speak to another person on the
other hand I can treat you as a student
as not really being a person but just
being something they're say to generate
revenue for me or to get me good ratings
on ratemyprofessor.com or to get off of
my back so I can get to my important
research you know these are the sorts of
traps that professors sometimes fall
into
in the course of their teaching so we
can think of all sorts of other examples
and other venues as well if I don't
treat you as a person I am imposing an I
it relationship there's a dynamic where
you know there's an imbalance is
introduced a difference is
institutionalized you might say who are
imposed yeah I treat myself as having
greater value than you I treat you as
having value only insofar as you satisfy
the the demands the desires the needs
that I have or you know insofar as you
fit into some other scheme but I don't
treat you as another me as something
else having value able to set ends for
itself able to chart out its own way of
life if I was you know another great
example again I'm having to do with
pedagogy people ask me all the time
where should I start I want to start
studying philosophy you know what should
I do what textbook should I get and so I
always say we'll start with Plato
why Plato well you know because he's
really at the beginning not the you know
complete beginning but close enough and
you know it gives you the good set of
vantage points to start from and then
you can start moving out you know in
other places and you know sometimes they
take my advice and sometimes they don't
you know now if I were to say you can
only start with Plato and if you do
anything other than that you're an idiot
don't even talk to me after that I would
be in effect imposing an eye the eye it
relationship upon you I would be
degrading your personality by the action
not treating you in a way that shows any
sort of mutual respect you know and
there can be mutual respect
even in imbalanced relationships if
you're coming to me as a student and
you're seeking my advice as a professor
there is an imbalance there but I can
still treat you as a person while
recognizing that you don't have you know
twenty years of studying philosophy and
like I do so that I can come to better
judgments about where you ought to start
I can still treat you as somebody who is
worthy of respect as somebody who can
set their own goals
they're being given advice is not
actually looking for a iron cage of
rationality you know to use mocks
Bieber's phrase to be imposed upon them
but rather to be given something that
would be useful for them which then they
can decide to do so you know when we
treat persons as persons we are
uplifting human personality and this may
not only be a matter of sort of negative
you know keeping our hands off allowing
the other person to do what they're
doing but something positive when we're
doing things like outreach that takes
somebody who's vulnerable and improve
their situation in some way or sometimes
even when we confront somebody but we do
it in a loving way and say look you're
screwing up buddy you got to fix this
and here's some resources to do that
with and I'd love to see you you know
moving along this way because it hurts
me to see you in such such confusion and
pain when we do that we're uplifting
human personality when we treat people
in ways that degrade them that humiliate
them that subjugate them that exploit
them we reduce them to objects we are
degrading human personality even as
we're making use of human personality
when we treat people as responsible so
that we can punish them or penalize them
but we don't treat them as responsible
in allowing them to have any of the
privileges that want to you know
counterbalance that we are degrading
human personality Martin Luther King
would say another way that we could
think about this is that we're not
damaging human personality so you know
when it comes to segregation he says
this is you know very clearly against
the natural law the eternal law the
moral law however you want to consider
it
why because segregation degrades the
human personality what does it do it
doesn't in two different ways he says it
gives some people and inflated and you
know ungrounded sense of superiority and
it gives other people a wrong sense of
inferior
now what would be wrong won't be bad
about giving somebody an inflated
unfounded sense of superiority
how are you damaging their personality
isn't that good you know you're you're
increasing their self-esteem
well you're keeping them from being able
to actually grow by by giving them a
wrongheaded conception of how good they
are you're depriving them of the
opportunity to ever say man I need to
you know make something better of myself
so you know when it came to whites and
blacks in the south you know the wing
that things were working under
segregation no matter how bad of a
person a white person was that you can
always say well at least I'm not a black
person and you know what did that
preclude you know if you've got some
sort of problem that you should be
working on on yourself so that you can
make yourself into a better person you
know let's say you beat your children
you know and bully them and abuse them
you can say well at least I'm not like
those black people over there no you're
you're you're a terrible bully and a
terrible person and you're probably
worse than them but you don't realize it
because you've been given this sense of
superiority by the the way the laws work
by the way the society is structured by
who gets opportunities and who doesn't
on the other side you have the sense of
inferiority yeah you know leads to what
King at one point calls a pervasive
sense of nobody this there were so many
abuses that were going on so many times
repeated over and over again it was such
a pervasive aspect of segregated culture
that people would come to the conclusion
that they really didn't matter as
persons in a sense they're non persons
Ralph Ellison has a novel that's written
really around the same era called the
Invisible Man and it deals with this
this sense and he's in the north racial
inferiority as something that was you
know pushed by the culture that you know
when when you when you're considered to
be nobody you
are actually invisible to everybody else
unless you constitute a problem and then
you know just crush the the problem make
make them conform and so King is saying
that this is clearly unjust the laws
that pertain to segregation are damaging
to the human personality not only of the
oppressed and that's bad enough but also
to the oppressor who seems to be getting
a good deal out of it a little bit later
on he'll say something else that's
particularly important as well well
oftentimes people want to frame things
in terms of law and order and King
reminds us that law and order exists for
the purpose of establishing justice they
do not embody or exhaust justice on
their own so there's some sort of higher
standard that has to govern laws that
has to govern order that has to govern
the execution the enforcement of laws
with policies with individual actions
and for King it's going to be this this
interesting criteria of whether it
promotes or whether it degrades human
personality now there are a set of
obligations that we can talk about in
relation to this a king again wants to
reassure the the fellow clergy people
and they give you the greater audience
of this work that they are not
lawbreakers that they are actually doing
the right thing in having these
demonstrations so he says there's
actually an obligation or responsibility
to obey just laws there's an obligation
on everybody's part to do what's in
accordance with the moral law to do
what's in accordance with the natural
law to do the things that would actually
promote human personality or recognize
human personality to not do the things
that would go against that this provides
something that applies not just to King
and his followers but everybody in
society on the other hand there is an
obligation or responsibility he says to
disobey unjust laws
it's not enough just to say well we'll
follow the laws that are good laws and
the laws that have bad laws well just
not you know pay attention to that stuff
over there we'll kind of like pretend
like we're not listening kay says no if
you're really a moral person and there
are unjust laws in place you have a
responsibility to break those laws to
undermine those laws to call attention
to them it's not enough just to stand by
and to say well I'm just not going to
follow them and it doesn't have to lead
to violence we're going to talk about
that in a moment but there is some
responsibility to stand up against them
he gives you some some great examples of
this he says there's nothing new about
this kind of civil disobedience it was
evidence in the refusal of Shadrach
Meshach and nego to obey the laws of
Nebuchadnezzar the Babylonian captivity
is a biblical story on the ground that a
higher moral law was at stake it was
practiced by the early Christians who
are willing to face you know torture
rather than to submit to certain unjust
laws of the Roman Empire to the certain
degree he says academic freedom is a
reality today because Socrates practiced
civil disobedience in our own nation the
Boston Tea Party was another act of
civil disobedience so the Boston Tea
Party interesting case he's saying the
Boston Tea Party which is an anti-tax
revolt was you know people following
through on their responsibility to
disobey unjust laws so we all have a
responsibility not only to follow just
laws but to stand up and to resist
injustice when we find it how are we
supposed to do that so here's where
civil disobedience comes in so the law
breaking it has to be done and there's
three conditions from this it has to be
done openly openly means that you're not
concealing the fact you're breaking the
law so you know for example if you think
that the tax codes are unfair you don't
simply you know
sweep everything under the rug you
actually say look I'm not going to pay
these taxes and you get you know you can
do what you're going to do but I'm not
paying this tax that goes through this
unjust purpose of oppressing people or
destroying communities I just won't do
it you know when it comes to other
issues you know certainly actions are
automatically going to be done fairly
open they could there's a lot of
possibility for concealment so King is
saying no you have to be upfront about
it lovingly well it has to be done not
only out of a sense of you know justice
but out of a attempt not necessarily to
feel lovey dovey towards the oppressor
but to treat them in a loving fashion it
doesn't do any good to you know if
you're gonna say that that just laws
should uplift human personality unjust
laws should not damage it or degrade it
it doesn't do any good for a person who
is breaking an unjust law to degrade
somebody else's personality so for
example you know the common practice
Martin Luther King would not go along
with people calling cops pigs when they
were doing resistance they would have to
treat the the police even though the
police may be engaging in brutality
towards them they'd have to treat the
police in a loving way otherwise the
whole thing breaks down accepting
whatever penalties are imposed there is
another another criterion a willingness
to accept the penalty she says I submit
that an individual it breaks a law that
conscience tells them is unjust and who
willingly accepts the penalty of
imprisonment in order to arouse the
conscience of the community over its
injustice is in reality expressing the
highest respect for law so this is how
one expresses the highest respect for
law and for morality in general you
could think of this as what King is
saying is the the civil rights
demonstrators are actually obeying a
higher law they're going against unjust
laws that other people think are
for the moment our just laws precisely
in order to show them that they are
unjust laws and to issue a call to them
to quit following unjust laws and to
align themselves with just ones and
thereby to participate in a larger
community which would be in improving
their own personalities he also gives us
three interesting what he calls examples
unjust laws and these are worth taking a
look at he says an unjust law is a code
that a numerical or power majority group
compels a minority group to obey but
does not make binding on itself so you
have a case of the majority versus the
minority imposing some sort of condition
on them and not actually following that
condition itself it treating them as
what we call second-class citizens or
third or fourth or even non citizens
that is an example of unjust laws why
well let's think about this criteria of
degrading personality how does it feel
to have somebody else telling you to do
something that they themselves don't do
doesn't have to be by the way in terms
of law it could be in terms of family
dynamics thinking about your you know
experience when your parents told you to
do things or not to do things that they
didn't follow themselves you know great
example smoking I you know my mother and
father when I was a kid
smoked at the dinner table until it
finally quit smoking and neither one of
them actually did quit smoking they'd go
off and sneak puffs here and there the
rest of their life my dad's life was
very short unfortunately my mom's life
was fairly short so you know the who
knows what they would have done and you
know old age but they told us kids you
should never smoke
it's a terrible thing to do and you know
they were actually right but of course
both of us you know my sister his turn
is smoking when we are in our teens and
you know we enjoyed it quite a bit
I think both of us are quit now but
there is that sensible who are you to
tell me not to do something when you're
doing it yourself what's the feeling
that goes along with that it's a feeling
of powerlessness it's a feeling of being
treated as less than a person so you
know and when a majority does that to a
minority imposes conditions on them that
they themselves don't follow
particularly with a legal regime it's
going to make people sense that they're
being degraded that their their
personality is not being respected he
says this is difference made legal
adjust law is a code that a majority
compels a minority to follow but that
majority follows it itself this is
sameness made legal so if we want to say
that nobody gets to you you know public
demonstrations then nobody gets sent
public demonstrations that's a bad law
anyway but if we want to say everybody
has to pay a certain tax a certain
amount of their their income then
everybody has to do it not just you know
the poor and the middle class have to
pay the taxes and the rich are able to
find all sorts of havens or exemptions
or get amnesty those would be examples
of unjust laws he was you another
example he says a law is unjust if it is
inflicted on a minority that as a result
of being denied the right to vote he had
no part in enacting or devising the law
this was indeed the case in the South
the the Jim Crow regime had
systematically excluded African
Americans from voting and often in areas
where they were the majority if they
were allowed to vote not having a right
to express oneself within the political
community and at the same time having
the power of law imposed upon one again
turns a person into effectively a legal
non person a mere subject but
a citizen and king is calling attention
to the degrading function that this has
third example has to do with the
application this is where it gets really
you know really sticky and also really
important you can have wands that on
their face appear to be just you know
you can require for example in the case
that they're talking about there that if
you're going to have a demonstration or
a parade or a march you have to get a
permit it's the application of laws that
by themselves could be proper you know
perfectly fine just whatever you want to
say prudent when the application is
unjust when it is used to go against
people and their development when it's
used to treat people unfairly then the
law itself can become unjust at least in
its application that is exactly what was
going on in Birmingham he says he says
an ordinance like that becomes unjust
when it is used to maintain segregation
and deny citizens the First Amendment
christa mend ment privilege of peaceful
assembly and protest so what are we
really talking about here in terms of
application we can think about it in
three ways one would be the intent if
you're passing a law just to try to
screw a bunch of people over to keep
them from actually practicing something
that should be there they're free rights
when you're using it just to get in
their way
that's an unjust law in application when
a law is function is to do that sort of
thing and there's no conscious intent
but there's kind of a subconscious let's
keep those people down mentality
promoting it then it's still unjust even
if the effective it turns out to be
unjust turns out to be unfair turns out
to be degrading to people once you
become aware of that even if the
original intent was not to try to hurt
anybody or to you know put anybody in a
one down position once you become aware
that the effect of laws and policies is
in fact the great human purse
analogy then you become responsible for
engaging that as an unjust law in a
great example of this would be thinking
about our current prison systems I don't
want to say system because we actually
have a whole bunch of systems those are
you know examples of application of the
criminal justice code and a lot of
pretty horrific things go on a lot of
very exploitative things go on once you
become aware of those things going on
Martin Luther King says you've got a
certain responsibility so all of this is
geared towards figuring out how to
address this issue unjust laws and
unjust law like I said at the beginning
turns out not really to be a law at all
it doesn't just lack binding force like
a just law why actually has a
responsibility Martin Luther King says
to go against it